par pas mal de petits trucs de
transition commencée on vient de publier
un livre
le nouveau livre qui vient de sortir
c'est le fabuleux chantier rendre
intelligent certifiait le robuste au
moins bénéfique pouviez donc remédier et
moi aux éditions e dp science c'est bien
paraître aujourd'hui vous pouvez
retrouver sur amazon fnac et tous les
distributeurs habituels et je pense
qu'on signale cependant vraiment content
tc livre veut dire qu'on a beaucoup
appris sur nous mêmes on écrit on se lit
tout d'abord quand on parle de sécurité
de l'ia ou de la rendre bénéfique
beaucoup de personnes pensent qu en
parle dit ah super sophistiqué d'un
futur lointain
c'est donc un chantier qui peut attendre
sauf que les ja nous ont déjà envahi sur
tous les téléphones à travers tout ce
qui est recommandations sur les réseaux
sociaux facebook twitter et youtube etc
c'est une affaire d'algorithmes très
bête et pas forcément très intelligent
mais déjà ultra puissants qui sont déjà
déployés qui influencent l'opinion
publique les élections de la plus grande
puissance mondiale etc
et ça ça pose toutes sortes de problèmes
en termes de confidentialité de guez
algorithmique de polarisation
d'addiction à la haine via nous ont déjà
envoyé surtout sur le téléphone
en fait on a énormément de points qui
ont été générés par le fait que les
algorithmes les plus déployées
d'aujourd'hui ceux qui sont sur les
plateformes comme facebook twitter et
youtube maximise la tension juste le son
reprendre et parmi les grands problèmes
que posent intelligence artificielle
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle recommande
de toutes sortes de contenus qui sont
pas forcément de très bonne qualité
informationnel comme par exemple des
contenus d'anti vaccination ou également
des contenus qui polarise et ça a
conduit à de nombreux cas déjà reconnu
très problématique notamment le génocide
d'une d'héroïne gaou mainemare ou encore
les problèmes d'anti vaccination qui
causent retour de dizaines de milliers
de morts d'après l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
donc il ya vraiment moyen de dire que
l'intelligence artificielle telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
tu déjà et tu pas directement mais elle
tue déjà indirectement donc je fasse
gaffe à être dans le même endroit non et
le gros problème c'est que si on ne fait
rien ça risque de continuer chaque année
qui passe sans solution technique d'où
l'urgence de rang des intelligences
artificielles bénéfique
malheureusement c'est pas une tâche
facile ils sont donc urgent de faire
quelque chose et donc une première étape
c'est de convaincre les géants du web de
rendre leur ya bénéfique car m
mais c'est qu'une partie du problème la
question de rendre un algorithme ont un
algorithme qui prend des décisions sur
beaucoup de d'utilisateurs bénéfique
n'est pas juste une histoire d'attention
elle est techniquement très difficile en
fait la grosse difficulté technique de
rendre des intelligences harcèleront bus
man bénéfique
parmi d'autres mais l'une des plus
grosses c'est considérer les effets
secondaires des intelligences
artificielles lorsqu'elles sont déployés
à très très très grande échelle comme
c'est le cas des systèmes de
recommandation voilà comment on vient de
verser production d'intention
l'intention ne suffit pas oui parce que
bien souvent en fait elles sont
déployées avec un objectif qui paraît
pas si malsain comme maximiser la
tension mais c'est vraiment
l'optimisation de cet objectif pas si
mal sa très très grande échelle qui fait
qu'on a tous les effets secondaires dont
on a déjà parlé notamment la promotion
de contenu de faible qualité
informationnel il doit mentionner terre
plate comme le suggère le titre ce livre
n'est pas juste un livre pour parler de
problème il ya seulement un tiers c'est
le premier tiers du livre qui fait un
qui dresse le bilan qui fait un état des
lieux de ce qui pose déjà problème
autrement dit on ne parle pas uniquement
de ce qui ne va pas non on parle aussi
de ce qu'il faudrait faire pour que ça
aille mieux il ya beaucoup de
difficultés techniques qui sent assez
transdisciplinaire ya des difficultés
mathématiques pour agréger des données
de plusieurs dimensions
il ya des difficultés juridiques réguler
un environnement technologique qui
changent de manière incessante l'aller
courte je vais pas me mêler les pinceaux
il ya des difficultés qui relève de la
psychologie de la sociologie
il s'agit de mettre en évidence une
série de questions qui balaie un champ
assez large ce livre contient en fait
énormément de réflexion
pluridisciplinaire y compris de
nombreuses publications récentes venant
de toutes sortes des disciplines qu'on
soit un terme à titien informaticiens
journalistes sociologues juristes je te
faire la transition
pour avoir lu le premier livre de l'est
je peux vous assurer qu'on a essayé
d'être beaucoup plus accessible que le
premier livre et promis il n'y a aucune
équation dans ce livre ok mais là il y
en a une mais ces réformes devaient donc
ça compte pas le public cible est
beaucoup plus large ici face aux
fabuleuses
il ya quelque chose de fabuleux dans ce
chantier c qui touche à un aspect assez
fondamentale de la nature humaine
ce qui a fait progresser notre
civilisation c'est les manières de
traiter l'information seller manière
d'évoluer dans nos supports de
traitement de l'information en passant
de l'écriture à l'imprimerie aventures
de l'algèbre à l'informatique puis
aujourd'hui à l'automatisation de cette
même informatique
on touche là au coeur de ce qui fait
fonctionner nos sociétés je peux
reprendre ça peut poser toutes sortes de
problèmes d'essuie tout un chantier qui
sont en chantier
pluridisciplinaire prophète de la même
manière que mon premier livre était une
compilation de toutes sortes de
résultats importants pour comprendre le
mécanisme
ce livre est une compilation de toutes
sortes de résultats importants de toutes
sortes de disciplines pour mieux
comprendre le fabuleux chantier pour
rendre l'intelligence artificielle
robustement bénéfique ce qui peut être
l'un des plus fabuleux chantier jamais
entrepris par l'humanité
rien que ça